this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
and we start with that breaking news
that we've been following all morning
long coming out of the southwest valley
that's right right now roads closed near
flamingo and rainbow we have metro
police on the scene a very serious car
crash hector mejia live at the scene
right now with the latest hector good
morning
good morning this investigation out
reaching its third hour this crash
involving two cars looks like both cars
caught fire take a look at what's left
of one of those vehicles basically a
shell of a car those two vehicles left
on rainbow the northbound lanes right at
spring valley parkway south the closure
of rainbow stretches from around
flamingo down to tropicana while
investigators are on the scene right now
and in the last hour or so we saw a bit
of a terrifying scene as someone drove
through this crime scene hit some of the
debris ended up between the two cars
involved in this earlier crash while
detectives were still in the street as
far as this investigation goes metro
police confirms fatal detectives have
taken over the investigation but they
have not said or given out a number of
injuries or fatalities
cena is still out here rainbow's still
closed between flamingo and tropicana we
have live team coverage for you let's
send it over to nate tannenbaum who has
traffic nate hey hector yeah we got some
detours for you but we're going to start
with the overall freeway traffic map
because maybe you don't go that way the
overall freeway system is okay right now
it's busy on the 15 and super crowded in
both directions on the 95 515 but let's
head on down now rainbow completely
closed between flamingo and tropicana
hector just told us what's going on out
there it looks like from a regional
transportation camera that flamingo is
doing okay it is rainbow that you cannot
use so how do you get around let me go
back to that because i kind of
disappeared that one too quickly for you
uh here's what we're talking about with
rainbow closed go east over to jones or
west over to buffalo so flamingo and
trop are ok it is rainbow that is closed
we will continue to have updates for you